let's see what's next all right up next
a writer at vogue recently explored this
interesting question what if your
friends don't like your partner
for some it could be a total deal
breaker they'll just cut loose a lover
if they can't vibe with their friends
but on the other end of the spectrum
some say they actually prefer a healthy
separation between their partner and
their friends because it helps them see
all sides of themselves here's the deal
right
there is a choice you have to make if
your friends tell you they don't like
your partner you have to think are they
seeing something i'm not saying and or
or is my relationship with them more
important than my relationship with my
partner and i don't think there's a rule
for everybody it's got to be case by
case what do you think i agree with that
how many people here would be honest and
just be like i'm just not like gelling
with your partner how many people would
actually be honest and say that
i like it
not that many how many people would just
like quietly bite it and like kind of
drift a little bit apart
show the hands if you don't mind i love
it um why were you giggling up there
yeah i mean um you have to be honest and
also to not ruin everything so it's
difficult
you ruined everything
i believe i heard a voice that said
something about you ruined everything
wait please please what what did he ruin
two two days ago
i i asked him to marry me on the broken
blade on the brooklyn bridge and he said
to me
oh no it's embarrassing get up
yes you did that
no
okay
what does this have to do with a friend
nothing nothing
i had to do this
now what
now because i wanted to do it myself
later
not today
we'll save it for an intimate moment
i'm getting the sense you don't like a
crowd
right
that was an emotional rollercoaster
[Music]